[Music]
so don't give me some [ __ ] stop story
here I know what the [ __ ] is happening
here you got your perspective hey guys
it's Gary Vaynerchuk so in this new year
in 2020 we're doing a bunch of different
formats
for the podcast and content not just
kind of putting it all in the umbrella
of the askgaryvee show which is super
ironic because this episode of the audio
experience we're gonna be interviewing a
author but the 100 I'm sure Colin is so
uncomfortably remarkable and we'll find
out all out but 100% of the reasons that
he is sitting here is because India the
former star of the askgaryvee show now
works with him because she moved for all
you super hardcore og askgaryvee fans
India's actually in studio so I know
you're all fired up but but this uh this
part of the conversation is about Colin
so Colin for everybody who is listening
give them the kind of framework of who
you are and what this book that just
came out is about and and then we'll get
into some jamming yeah absolutely Gary
it's great to be here and we are
grateful to have India on the team she
moved to the west coast my hometown
Portland Oregon so I guess that's a
little bit where my story starts I'm
from Portland Oregon
the book that came out today is called
the impossible first from fire to ice
crossing Antarctica alone I last year
became the very first person in history
to cross Antarctica solo completely
unsupported and I needed so no outside
support had to carry all my food and
fuel with me 375 pounds sled 54 days all
alone adventurers and explorers have
been attempting this feat for over a
hundred years some people ever died
attempting it no one had ever mailed to
do it before and I kind of cracked the
code once a dude I would just quit and
turn around
yeah we're like run out of food or run
out of supplies and call for support
obviously getting support or pick up
middle of Antarctica is not an easy
thing but it can be done you can be
extracted but the reason the title is
called from fire to ice is 12 years ago
actually the book came out today but
it's also the 12 year anniversary of a
tragic accident in my life I was
severely burned in a fire 12 years ago
in Thailand and the doctors told me I
would never walk again normally so it's
humbling but also a proud day to know
that that that diagnosis was wrong I was
able to recover from that
and achieve some things on the other end
of it that I never thought were possible
at the time so how'd you do it I noticed
something you talked a lot about but
it's really the power of the mind the
mind set something for me that will
finally like help me in my life yes is
being cold a mindset it's being called a
mindset you know I think that you
definitely right and everybody like like
makes fun of me for this and then I'm
always like but I'm from Belarus and I
make this joke that like I was from
Russia so but I don't believe that [ __ ]
cold not if I don't want to right right
I mean it was the average temperature in
Antarctica was about minus 30 degrees
every single day I was pulling my cell
12 plus hours a day
windchill minus 70 degrees and I was
Arthur alone for two months and I didn't
end up with any severe frost but
anything like that a few little frost
nips on my nose I'm not sure it was all
in my mind I wasn't walking out there
completely naked when I went off did a
blurb the book but I don't know if you
can make it completely naked out there
but definitely was able to keep myself
warm particularly you're pulling a
binary thing to your point right it's
not like you're gonna like you know I
was I guess my punchline is this I'm I'm
I failed all my science classes so that
didn't put me in a position to really
know the answer to any of these
questions but on my intuition I'm wildly
fascinated by people under estimating
the power of the brain absolutely I mean
that's what feels so right to me and
even like the reaction of the room like
I don't bro I really believe in it
that's I mean that's my truth as I said
you know from fire dice people say how
did you get out of this tight Hospital
so go deeper into the book obviously but
real quick
I was jumping a flaming jump rope in
Thailand when I was 22 years old not the
brightest me ever this story right yeah
I think I've told you this before around
my legs remind me where we cross paths
on this because I know this story and
like when you start telling I'm like
[ __ ] I know this story yeah and I was
like oh right like I know this story
yeah we I've been in here before no AJ
that's right you know man
why is this like so obvious to me yes
yes once just once it's yeah my dear
friends had dinner with her last night
shoutout to Swan and a dear friend of
yours so got a lot of mutual folks yes
but anyways 12 years ago yeah so the
Rope wraps around my legs let my body
completely on fire to my neck I have to
dive in the ocean to extinguish the
flames I'm on a tiny little island in
Thailand there's no proper Hospital
moped ride to it at the time but like
why did that happen like why'd you [ __ ]
up on the Rope thousands of people do
that every night in Thailand and I just
had bad luck I excess kerosene on the
rope and it just splattered me and lit
me on fire but the piece about the
mindset that was key was in that
hospital there's a cat running around my
bed in the ICU yes sir my mom saying you
know the doctors say to me you'll never
walk in normally and my mother
incredible woman that she is she flies
all the way over to Thailand to kind of
rescue me she walks in and she's crying
in the hallways you know pleading for
good news from the doctor but she
shields me from that fear she walks in
she goes calling like what's your goal
what do you want to do with the rest of
you're 22 years old your life is not
over and I was kind of like I don't know
I'm like dark deep dark spiral downward
spiral and she's like no seriously what
is your goal and I go close my eyes and
I was like mom I just visualized myself
crossing the finish line of the
triathlon I figured she was gonna look
at me and go like yeah I said set a goal
but look at your legs the doctor said
you're not gonna walk in she goes
alright that's your goal let's do that
let's talk about it every day let's
visualize it let's get it in your mind
[ __ ] about triathlons I've never done it
before I swam in college but like it
just in my mind when I figured like
what's a fit person I guess I'm thinking
a a highlight reel of like the Kona
Ironman or something popped into my head
I'd never done a trough on before and so
you know it's a long story when did you
do this this so the trot the Antarctica
crossing was last year that what the
book is nice showing you but the burn
axe and I haven't done it yet right
we're gonna yeah I had a couple other
ones like you
yeah I remember did you tell me you were
going - I'm trying - I remember it I'm
remembering a lot more that meeting yeah
you see we're going toward it wasn't had
just come off a different world record
project where I set the speed record for
climbing the tallest mountain each of
the seven continents and yes of the
Interpol so I was called the explorers
Grand Slam but then going all the way
back to you know the burn axe in
2009-2010 I was recovering from that
movie Chicago because I needed a job as
a commodities trader for a quick comment
yeah real quick you're really good at
doing crazy-ass [ __ ] you know what I'm
really good at selling books
alright so sell these books here's how
we're gonna do it you're not gonna tell
the whole [ __ ] book I'm not yeah so
we're done with that story we're going
somewhere else the public and do 800
other things where you'll tell the whole
thing everybody please just buy this
book for India
okay so Colin talk to me about this
weirdoes like I actually want you to go
Rick it's funny now I'm like vibing and
that's why I interrupted you happy I
love it by the way I love it by the way
Andy you're gonna love this we're we're
launching interrupted by Gary Vee as my
interview show yes right because look I
have to own it like III yeah because you
know what they're gonna say I know it's
a gift and a curse all right listen I
love it I'm with it that's right all
right let's sell these books talk to me
how much I want you to go very real cuz
I think you can actually help a lot of
you help a lot of people through this
I'm gonna give you a curveball that I
think you're gonna hit and bring a lot
of value because I think this is very
interesting to me how much of what
you're going through right now
do you think about in like a personal
brand
evel knievel way personal branding of a
family yeah in a way your your
strategizing you're living this life now
you're still young still yeah you were
young at 22 laying there with you know
firon and now you're young again yes
putting these wins on the board you're
you've figured out a way to play with
your brain that's making [ __ ] happen yep
you've got this book that's gonna do
what I'll say please I'll say this he's
that my wife Jenna Vsauce she's in the
room she is really not only my wife and
a credible person but my business
partner and her and I and we do talk
about this in the book and I think this
appeals to your audience I'm not gonna
talk about the book I might say but this
is that you self can you read the book
verbatim here right now for the rest
so page one fired ice crossing an
article alone
no so actually are you doing an audio
book I read it my son you that's where
the first I'm gonna read the first line
because I think you might enjoy it I
believe I will the first line of the
book is I started thinking about my
hands that was my first mistake you said
boom you're in a little too fast a few
hundred of a beat I've been more in but
one thought one thing that we talked
about in this book which is we frame it
as from whiteboard into reality yes it
is about the adventure in the feet but
Jenna and I sat in a one-bedroom
apartment had no money had nothing about
no nothing about marketing branding
hanging this up the first project we're
gonna do was going to cost half a
million dollars we have ten thousand
dollars to our name a life savings and I
go we're gonna do this project we go
wait we don't know about anything of
marketing and PR we literally pull out
our laptops Norma return Google what's
the difference between marketing and PR
mean we're asking the most basic
questions like the Internet's here like
let's just start figuring [ __ ] out wait
that article should show up first
okay so literally that starts happening
and we go we start talking to you we
need sponsorship we need funding talk to
a thousand people no no no you have 200
Instagram followers while we'll be a
part of this no no no but we kept
hustling we kept grinding we finally
found a couple people to believe in us
and this and now we've pulled out
projects at a massive scale but it
started there it's how every single
thing happens everybody thinks it's like
manifesting the secret no here it is you
know what you're trying to accomplish
and then you have the humility to do the
steps to accomplish it which caught
which causes you to deploy an incredible
amount of patience and an incredible
amount of grind and dirt absolutely and
that's asking at scale asking so many
people I'm recognizing I so I talk a lot
about like ask DM people ask and I get
so much pushback from people after they
do it yeah like I read my DMS I read my
stuff Gary you're [ __ ] you told me to
DM 50 [ __ ] famous people to eat [ __ ]
and be their admin get close to the
[ __ ] Sun you [ __ ] [ __ ] this
that the other thing done
and I'm like and like every time I just
don't like like dude you want to be the
next [ __ ] great director in Hollywood
and you think that you it's oh you gave
up after DMing fifty people and
Instagram while taking a [ __ ] on a
Thursday after we had said after we had
said a thousand people it said no to us
we had only raised that was funny we
only raised we'd only raised a hundred
and fifty grand
I'm leaving in six weeks we need the
other three hundred fifty thousand and
I'm still doing press I'm like I'm doing
this I'm I'm ready let's go let's keep
knocking on doors and I'm not gonna give
away the whole thing in the book but how
do you talk about we're gonna bounce
we're stop I mean I stop I want to clip
it do you think like even Evel Knievel
like do you think No okay so truth is no
okay I am NOT framing this around me
doing more stunts and people watching me
what I want with this book in the way
that she's written really no yes this is
true this is handed please is the book
is called the impossible first but it is
not me yes it's edge-of-your-seat
adventure storytelling you'll like it
it's a page-turner it's an epic story
whatever I loved it hold on I wanna
finish out my brain works I know you're
the interrupted bellowing fierce is one
thought this one please bro you can do
that one thought eight thousand other
[ __ ] places in my [ __ ] show you
has to be on you [ __ ] India so don't
give me some [ __ ] stop story I know
what the [ __ ] is happening here it was
all my wife where it said I want to meet
Gary Vee and I said [ __ ] I better hire
the girl he she's no noise Coast and
here it is reality he redid that's why I
said that's the last chapter book but no
for real know your master your question
is about Evel Knievel which is it would
be easy for us to frame our brand
candidly it was easy to be like here's a
dude that does badass [ __ ] watch what
you got action like David Goggin expect
like this brand is like on fire I mean
he's just the badass [ __ ] it is
hard chord stuff like you know and like
it's some of the energy a lot of people
are motivated by I'm saying
knock on him at all tons of love for me
he's got the thing they like doing for
me like my heart is not fully in that
after doing this just two weeks ago I
just got back from rowing a boat across
Drake Passage 700 miles to Antarctica in
a tiny little rowboat no one the world's
ever done that either but I'm not
sitting here telling you that story
necessarily but why are you putting that
W on the board I'm fascinating it's
really clever and I don't think it's up
I'm sorry clubbers not fair it I'm
fascinated to you just brought that up
like what goes what are you doing here's
what I think here's my thesis is I think
you're doing my thesis is this please is
that my canvas if I think of myself as
an artist is endurance sports in the
outdoors I love doing that I'm
passionate about it it makes good a
thing I'm good at it clear however I
think the mindset the skills the
creativity the hustle whatever you want
to call that can be manifested in any
modality that could be entrepreneurship
that could be love that could be buzz
ring and I call this book the impossible
first I hope that people put this book
down that's not [ __ ] and I don't
like Pat me on the back of the con
you're an amazing athlete you have ten
world records you're so cool like that
is not an ROI for me the ROI is when
someone puts this book down and goes I'm
gonna do my impossible first now I'm
actually gonna not just DM those 50
people on Telegraph you want admiration
or legacy I want admiration legacy I
actually want the ripple effect of
positivity people actually doing status
[ __ ] yeah for what you understand like
for me I want admiration and legacy you
want on the Jets bro no I do not I want
the game of owning the Jets and then
when I own the Jets cuz I will you want
to ingest ooh okay well is it a race or
do you want to like jump ahead I'm not a
very selfish
I'm collabing on everything else I'm
very selfish on this one I think I think
you know it's really interesting it took
me a long time to know I'm listening to
you I'm always see the world through
optimism and and cynicism yeah right and
I always say to myself like it took me a
long long time I'm like [ __ ] why am I
like this like why am I not is motivated
by money even though I'm in this
entrepreneur why did I create this thing
called I want to buy the Jets for the
whole world to make everybody completely
confuse to think that's what I'm
actually up to that was your answer as
somebody who knows something like my my
deep wants and needs are to have
admiration and legacy I want all the
best [ __ ] that ever happens to me to
happen to me when I know that it didn't
happen meaning after I'm dead like to me
but that's like a fascinating thing to
understand why like I'm like why do I
want all the coolest [ __ ] to happen
where I don't even get to see it you
want to look back on it like is it for
you for your kids
my current hypothesis cuz you know this
is a forever [ __ ] game when you
whenever you're doing something even
slightly outside the lane you're you're
stuck asking yourself the [ __ ] the lane
so easy sure this is hard
absolutely um you know my intuition is
actually the statue when I'm dead is
exactly like buying the Jets I'm
obsessed with process and I kind of like
this idea that when the the end of my
process is actually the end of my life
sure you know and so I there's just as
deep curiosity of like okay that'll be
it that'll be triple zero and like and
then what but that's for you with this
is there isn't this the there's no
finish line right like there's no finish
on you want to continue to grow and
evolve and continue to keep stepping
outside that comfort zone
always and that's what it is for me
after setting two World Records in the
mountain it was like oh wait in it for
you but for me the day that is what what
is interesting because I think I think
we in society need to start having a
better relationship of the ability to
hold both selfish and selfless acts and
one we've become a binary culture where
it's black-white left right yes no and I
think we've completely gotten into a
place where we do not have more nuanced
conversations I am fascinated by my
ability to be selfless through my
selfish wants and needs of admiration
well I would say this you're saying that
I agree with this by leading by example
by actually living your full truth in
your full capacity you're actually
having a larger impact you're having
more resources but also by actually
sharing this by being on this project by
writing books by speaking other things
and I both do you've made it a bigger
level like that actually inspires people
not because you're like oh but it's not
about me you're like I'm doing this I
care about this I have to addiction
here's here's actually what's funny
about it is why I think you might be
somebody that might help you I'm curious
if you can like I'm hope like I'm hoping
you email me in 13 weeks and be like I
got something
because I think it's interesting thought
I think everything's about me which
makes everything I do nothing about me
silence because it's really thought like
let me make it very clear so it's not
confusing I only do what I want to do
every minute the end ironically quite a
bit of that leads to bringing an
uncomfortable level of value in
comparison to my contemporaries sure
well I think that what do people say
that I carry a lot of people could but
Gary why right let you for asking that
people I spoke on why would you walk
Crescent arnica why to me it's like
homeless market it's because it's so I
just want to do that because I just want
to tell the [ __ ] like yo [ __ ]
you I walked across st. Martha like you
know like you know to me that's like
what's cool about it like [ __ ] I Nate
who's my partner in empathy whines who
was my admin for many years who worked
here for a long time India knows him
well oh [ __ ]
I got a faced on my kids this is all
right we're gonna rapidly stop me yeah
you tell this story and let's get by you
a couple minutes here - so much I love
you all right I the I like to razz like
he was really was like a real like I
love when I've had Indian I have a very
special relationship like tre and I are
very close but like when you go into
like even into admin world it gets even
to like another deeper thing and so like
I'm always say about like what works how
do I bring people value and everybody
that I work with has different things
is it like do you go with radical candor
do you go with kindness do you randomly
call them do you randomly follow them do
you do what do you do what do you do to
like bring the most value to them talks
are you always there for do you make
them feel like you're there for them do
you try to build top when they move to
Portland do you try to make sure people
know about it so that's people that do
know me want that like I know what I'm
doing okay
so Nate I would always like razz about
like look I'm gonna have to go there
I've beaten Nate in tennis every time we
fight and what's even more fun that be
known and let that be known and more
importantly you know listen 10 World
Records
I beat Nate every time
number two Nate has been beating me in
tennis on three separate occasions five
to two to win the set which is what
we're talking about as we played one set
what happened in those games I decide
mentally not to lose now to your point
that if I went naked in Antarctica I
would freeze and die to death
it wasn't just that because then I would
have never lost a match in my life if
I've decided not to lose I would never
lose there's something in the
relationship of me and Nate that has
allowed me to do that but anyway I would
bring this up a bunch to razz him razz
him having fun real fun like you know
brother banter type stuff and then
finally like I was like I gotta like
help him figure out how to like counter
me so I said Nate don't tell me you
start intentionally losing to him are
you out of your I said no I said Nate
you're a scratch golfer people give a
[ __ ] about golf in society for whatever
reason yeah people like a lot of
different things like uh I said next
time I say to you and make fun of you in
front of people five - you asked me well
my handicap is well I've never golfed I
don't even know how that goes it's 79s
maybe eleven uh so now he uses that all
the time I'm just like it in your head
is a harder for you to battle back in
that set well my big thing is like like
everybody's got strengths and weaknesses
and like I'm very passionate about
people leaning into their strengths and
then ultimately and this is what's
making this interview fun for me is I
want people who have emotional
intelligence strengths to really I wish
to the world out there that was really
compassionate and empathetic and
sympathetic and kind realize they're the
strong and they can win the whole thing
they continue to buy into their
pushovers and people walk over them
that's because they don't realize that
they actually use kindness as a
manipulation not as a truth they're
getting walked over because they
actually weren't being kind their intent
was wrong they were trying to create
some sort of scenario but they did it in
a way that was too obvious so that's why
somebody walked over them but I think I
mean I hate to do this but I'm bringing
back the bullies last chapter of my book
is called infinite love and that is not
exactly what people would expect from a
bad attitude that goes alone and does
this super hard thing and no one ever is
done but in harnessing the positivity
harnessing the love harnessing that
compassion empathy my wife
team etc that's what I wanted to leave
behind with this legacy to go like no
one can kind of question me in terms of
like the difficulty the challenge what
I've been through whatever so I consider
you like but it's like hey I got there
not from having the most ruthless chip
in my shoulder I'm super ambitious I'm
gonna knock in a thousand doors and if I
don't get on a thousand time on a
knocking on a thousand and one but at
the same time where my mind went and the
barest I'm starving my ribs are
protruding I'm running out of food I
ended up pushing 77 miles in 32 hours
straight on the very last day because I
went to a place in my mind so deep and
flow so deep in commitment which is what
you're saying about the tennis match I'm
just not gonna lose and this is actually
a race there's another dude out there
battling me I live in that flow right I
actually live in that flow and that's a
beautiful most beautiful place than most
families
that we have to lick you know it's so
funny I'm so happy meditation you know
what's really under eyes breathing yes
I'm seeing that really breathing is no
really it's on the rise people are
really starting talking along breathing
first you know it's funny like I've been
talking about meditation for five years
I'm like look I don't meditate but I'm
sorry but I'm so pumped for other people
like that people like everybody finds
their thing like people some people love
running they get a runner's high I hear
you know like I get shin splints in one
second I want to kill the world like we
all have our things like my big thing
though is like quickly breathing is
really on the rise tons of people are
starting to really are getting into like
truly like being thoughtful about
breathing everything everyday person
Tana no no but listen I mean this really
cool this is really cool to me because I
want to put this out there because I
want people dig into it look you know
this notion of like if you exhale more
than you inhale it's like a very basic
thought of like get your brain thinking
that you're actually resting like I just
have had three separate front three
three separate friends who could not
sleep alcohol pills meditation reading
different beds sound machines oxygen
open window close window new rooms
moving planes walking I'm going through
it all three different friends with some
variations of those all get into great
sleeping behavior on five minutes of
breathing before they go to bed right
enough you got something for me on this
I don't know what we're talking about
but go ahead
some dude like so mad he's on the back
of the book and that's like a big thing
in your jewelry the impossible first
that's wonderful right sunset what yeah
breathing I'm breathing and cold and
breathing you do this [ __ ] yeah
but not all the time because it's
hardcore twice day you shower cold yeah
epic yeah well I think everything's easy
just [ __ ] talk to yourself into it
the meditation the meditation I did to
begin there's 10 years ago long before I
thought I was everyone do this is I got
introduced someone said go meditate I
never meditated a minute in my life and
I went and signed up for a 10-day of a
pasta of course 10 day no reading no
writing no eye contact and for me it was
was it difficult
yes but committing to my I want to do
this I want to take a deep immersion and
that train my mind to have the daily
practice that what you're talking about
Rock which is actually doing it daily
we're taking that deep dive first have
that full Murs and most people say I'm
not gonna do 10 days and listen earn up
to yes and for some people that's the
way it works for sure right like here's
what people to understand they listen to
podcasts like this and are like yeah
whatever like not what people understand
it's like there's 87,000 different ways
it's that we're not talking about all
the ways that didn't work first very
like like we're sitting here trying to
articulate all the things that did work
there's like a million things that don't
work it's about action but actually
keeping trying different things is
something work which goes to self esteem
because so many people are scared about
their loss publicly for sure how many in
your 10 World Records how many times
have you tried to create a world record
and not succeed before I said a single
world record I spent 20 years of my life
trying to make the Olympics and I didn't
make the Olympics I came close I fell
short in to sports and swimming and then
also in triathlon and then I kept
reinventing myself an out of 10 world
record so do you like that weird lung
thing I really love Nike runner guy when
he passed away like the guy vo2 Max sort
of like he like chopped him open he's
like had ribs
salams and tested a lot I think I have
pretty normal lungs you know I might
have it slightly better capacity than
the average person but I really I really
[ __ ] hate running yeah I heard the
shin splints man
yeah like a cop-out like I just don't
like it I love jump rope though I'm hot
on jump rope right now yeah you got to
breathe the jump rope high jump rope
high breathing I hate what reading no
really I know I don't like forcing
myself to breathe harder like I don't
like even like when I was like this is
recently on my radar which is why I'm
talking about like the whole exhale
harder I'm like I don't like that it's
like it's hard I like things that come
easy I actually do it's a very
interactive like it this is why I think
I talked so much about strikes I like
the things that come easy to me for most
people they're not a robot and can work
22 hours in a day like I did yesterday
like and by the way I think everyone
should sleep seven and eight and nine
hours yesterday serendipitously cuz I
went to the national championship game
and you got to go with the buggin
champion LSU players to the club if
you're in the sports representation
business you're [ __ ] in this business
and like and then my alarm didn't go off
then like [ __ ] all sorts of [ __ ]
happen today punchline is most people
can't do that I have natural energy
thank ya yes so I'm leaning into my
natural energy some people are pretty
dustin like i don't know how that being
a pretty life is but you know the
advantages really I really think in
wrapping this up there's no way look
there's a lot I do I believe that people
listening who are gonna be like I'm
gonna do that too I do not believe that
everyone was given the same group of
talents I do think that we should all
challenge ourselves to be self-aware and
try to figure out the talents and then
if we're lucky that those talents match
something we're interested in doing we
have to go pop committed to that but
what I would say as a final thought at
least for me please talk about my lungs
are they bigger are they stronger my Tom
and I'm pretty six-foot you know a tall
guy but what I say I believe the
strongest muscle that any of us have is
the six inches between our ears and
that's what we all have we are born with
a mind that we can flex and develop the
go with with what they wish it was
versus what it actually is the brain
can't listen I believe in the bro I
actually asked you because I actually
was asking yeah if cold is a brain thing
yeah
I think it is I don't know like I just
decided at some point like that I was
let me tell the transfer
I was losing coats all the time because
I'm quite absent-minded this is true I
would lose my coat and my mom would get
pissed like in like she's like what the
[ __ ] matter with you
because of me every time I get a coat
take it a school and I'd be like what
the [ __ ] my coat gonna be over so then
finally and I was just like you know
what I'm not gonna wear coats anymore I
don't need them and like I just
convinced myself that I'm I don't know
I'm just like oh god no coat I just
never wear a coat yeah so I don't know
what the [ __ ] is that
Jake right on the flip side I do not
think I can mentality myself to being
the starting quarterback of the New York
Jets I do not think I can mentality
myself to sing like Beyonce I don't I do
not do I think I can be a better
football quarterback in backyard
football yes I do do I think I can be a
better singer yes I do but we have to
have an understanding of like where that
well wouldn't you rather any know your
goal is not to actually play quarterback
for the Jets but wouldn't you rather set
the massively audacious goal and if you
fall short of it like I fell short of
the Olympics you still land them
somewhere and take what you've learned
along that way and develop it into the
next course I was interested in if you
were into source that's why I say to
people I thought auditions go what I
wouldn't do which is what I see from a
trillion [ __ ] comments is then come
up with unlimited amounts of excuses and
I blame to why I didn't become Beyonce
right but aim that high engaged the
process to a thousand times as ten
thousand times I believe it my brain
tells me that I'm the president United
States obviously I logically know that I
wasn't born his country but like I
really believed that if I was born his
country I would be the President of the
United States of America in next 20
years I really believe that if you had
to go between president or owning the
Jets what would you do if you had to
pick one or the other you know what's
funny my brain doesn't even work that
way because I can't be President I don't
like make pretend that's like asking me
if I want wings and fly
I'm not allowed would be cool though if
I could I'd [ __ ] win and I wouldn't
be big I just I just have I just like
humans and they like me back yeah I just
feel like listen everybody please pick
up this book it's important to India
and Colin too I guess thank you so much
for yeah thank you [ __ ] thank you
you